You ready yet?
Yeah
I hate rollercoasters.
Two households, both alike in dignity
In fair Verona, where we lay our scene
From ancient grudge break to new mutiny
Where civil blood makes civil hands unclean
From forth the fatal loins of these two foes
A pair of star-cross'd lovers take their life
Where misadven - Ow!
piteous... Ugh!
piteous overthrows
Do with their death bury their parents' strife
Agh!
Ugh!
The fearful passage of their death-mark'd love
Augh!
And the continuance of their parents' rage
Ugh!
Which
Which, but their children's end, nought could remove
Augh!
Is now - Oh!
Is now the two hours' traffic of our stage
The which if you with patient ears attend
What here shall miss, our toil
shall
shall - Oh!
strive to mend
Someone get me off this thing!
I really wanted to come off this and say, "Can we do that again?" but I really don't want to do that again.
[Translating these subtitles? Add your name here!]